foreign
[Music]
corridors remember that you are being
watched at all times
whether you're looking for a new outfit
somehow Decor or just a bite to eat we
have something for everyone
don't try to leave without buying
anything
but more importantly do not look at them
thank you
[Music]
foreign
wait wait a minute oh I didn't do what I
didn't do anything welcome to Harvest
Festival 64.
oh hello
[Music]
you must be new here
hang on this aspect ratio is not working
for me lexian put something spooky down
below me like a face that might just be
there it's fading just an in and out of
perceptibility but people don't really
know it's there I might just be playing
with them there might not be nothing
there at all
but you and I both know that there's
something there
don't you worry you will feel like at
home in no time
you don't have a place to stay yet no no
I don't you can stay at this house right
here for now the previous owner just
moved out
what a wonderful coincidence
and you are even more lucky
it's just four more days until our big
event
our
Harvest Festival this
Friday what a joke
we still have a few things left to do
for that of course we could use some
help
come back tomorrow see if either one of
us needs anything
thank you so much and Welcome to our
town
okay
mono9
wow is that a mushroom oh I can't have
it look at me go look at me I'm I'm
adorable I'm goddamn adorable I can't
move the camera can I no but I'm
adorable
hey what's up you need anything oh hello
I'm preparing some pumpkin pies for the
Harvest Festival but I need some more
pumpkins would you
be so kind and bring me some thank you
so much
all right I'm just gonna go see if the
other person needs a quest because it
seemed to be some planks of wood needed
hey green horn oh I can skip past have
you heard the storm last night good
thing nobody was hurt the bridge wasn't
so lucky though if I take some time to
repair you should check back tomorrow oh
I thought it was gonna need to do
something did I just eat that oh no in
my bag
all right this seems fine everything is
completely innocuous and definitely not
terrifying
you can do this yourself it took me like
a few seconds thank you so much now I
can make some Delicious Pies for the
Harvest Festival don't forget to try
them this
[Music]
oh
I I went to bed right after that I guess
ah
hi
green horn I'm still busy repairing sure
will be done by tomorrow in the meantime
I want to build a big bonfire for the
Harvest
could you grab me some wooden plank for
that thanks
you got it pal happy to be of service
anything for this glorious Community you
know what this music reminds me of is
that I have not played the Final Fantasy
7 remake yet I just have not had time
for it and I've been meaning to Forever
I don't know why but this remind me of
that
hey green horn that's all I need for now
thanks pretty sure the bridge will be
repaired by tomorrow see you at the
Harvest
all right good good night
okay
I guess they just disappeared
hello
[Music]
ah you look sickly
hey yo I know that I should do some
stuff for the yeah
but I'm so tired you know I'll start
tomorrow okay
a little lazy don't they know how
important the
Harvest Festival is
don't they know that hi
hello you have you seen any of these
shiny stones I love how shiny they are
can you help me find some more they're
just what I need for them
thank you
get shiny stones heart all right
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm kind of curious how this is all
gonna come to a head but maybe I'm just
applying too much horror themes to this
as it is and it's actually not that
terrifying
awesomely anyway
we shall see
oh they're so shiny thank you so much
hope to see you on Friday friend
wow
let me guess I gotta go gather mushrooms
is that what I gotta do hey yo I'm still
tired today would you mind giving some
more of them mushrooms yo I only need
like 10 or something and I really need
them today because
[Music]
it's happening tomorrow
thanks Jay you got it and you got it
man I can't wait for the heart
[Laughter]
my uh my soundboard betrayed me there my
soundboard really put me on the spot and
I I don't appreciate it I would I would
kindly like no one to ever mention this
moment ever again to me ever into this
why do I gotta get 10 of these
there's so many mushrooms I know my
skill building it going and collecting
things is pretty incredible
however I feel like I got more to
contribute to this down
oh I gotta get a mushroom down there
[Music]
doesn't this music have Final Fantasy
vibes
I don't know why
hey I did it zombie cat yo thanks a that
was some good work right there now I got
everything I need see you tomorrow at
the
great
it's Friday though
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
my God
[Music]
after we put all the shiny stones
wait
wait wait wait wait
a minute
oh
yeah
[Music]
I am wow
foreign
[Music]
this is
just delightful
I this Harvest Festival sorry this
is vegetable has exceeded my wildest
expectations
what
what was that I thought I uh saw
something there
must have been my uh imagination
foreign
[Music]
that's fine that's all good you know
what
I've had weirder things happen to me
I ain't gonna look into that at all what
happens if I just go into the ocean
can I do that
[Music]
beware of flashing lights everybody
can't move
[Music]
well I had a good time at the Harvest
Festival I think I missed a few of the
other cats there I don't think I was
able to talk to all of them but um I
love them
moving on
all right lidar this is lidar
so this game
is a little different than other games
that you may know why
that's what it is use Mouse scroll to
change their scan radius
Drive Mouse button for detailed scanning
what does that mean
oh my God
holy crap oh
wow
it's like power washing
but with a lidar so what it's doing is
it is just spitting out images and it's
creating a point Cloud projection of
where I'm pointing and it will make it
uh so that I can see what I'm doing
ish the problem is if I do too detailed
I won't be able to see anything
because it'll all be the same color
whoa that's weird
that's bizarre
oh
it's funky oh that's weird
oh that's very weird
creepy
[Music]
all right let's not do that too much I I
kind of want to actually scan
oh
cool
what could be lurking in the darkness
anything
could be lurking in the darkness wow
this is horrifying
oh
okay I don't know if there's any
specific objective besides just
exploring but this as a concept is just
fast fascinating
great the choices I have
good
what's that sound
what is that
what is that why are you sad why are you
sad don't be sad
it's a goose is our Goose here
is this a goose
is that a goose well damn it's a goose
or a duck I'm not sure which
am I supposed to be going in a spazoo
okay
good
what am I making seven one two eight is
the question
what needs to be seven one two eight
there's got to be like a keypad or
something that I'm going to punch in
eventually here I just don't know where
it is
because like oh never mind I see it
exit really
are you sure
ah it's not over yet
that's bizarre
oh this is a big cavern
oh
okay fascinating
you know
I don't know if this is just like I'm
blind and this is my tool that I use
that feeds information directly into my
brain but also isn't this how VR
headsets kind of like map out the
environment around them
let's make a bunch of calculations based
on point because this is green
why are you green
please tell me your grass
please tell me this is great oh it's
grass okay it is grass I'm okay good
good
that's not a tree oh I'm in a graveyard
foreign
well all in all you know the charm is
starting to wear off I can't exactly say
that I'm keeping it interesting
because at the end of the day it's just
trying to find my way with a lidar
there's a lot of potential here but
just waiting for something to happen I
don't have guidance so I just kind of
got to do whatever you want I look at it
what is this is this a ruined building
or something oh
[Music]
foreign
building
[Music]
I think anyway well where else to go
what am I supposed to do what am I doing
I found a building and so what it's
broken I can't live there I can't live
anywhere here
where am I going
why am I doing it
oh tunnel
okay I think I wait a minute
ah
we might have a problem
I don't know what animal
leaves these Prints but I don't think
it's going to be good for my health
that's pitch Blackness
wow that's Darkness
um what's what's oh
what oh
thank you
that was it
that was it what the
Fateh
but it was such a cool ganza but there's
so much that could be done no it was
cool it was really cool but it lasted
like just long enough that it started to
drag on and then suddenly I had no idea
what was going on and I died it's I
don't mean to be critical about it
because it's it's only I'm only
disappointed because there was so much
potential for something cool and it's
like it's interesting gameplay but not
interesting game still good still good
Andrew booger in Ken Forest thank you
moving on
this is do not play this game start
I'm ready
spook me
ah
hello
is someone there
where are you
oh my God
the soup's gone bad
oh no
someone hung that cross upside down
oh my God
something's not right here
I still don't know why I'm not supposed
to play this game
store
just
wow
that was incredible look this person
made this game in 30 minutes what are
you doing with your life huh look at
what they made in 30 minutes come on
dream big Dream High dream hard dream
hard stay hard
stay dreaming hardly
moving on
oh oh we're going right into it
um this is a mall near you all right
kiddo you got all the stuff in your
backpack right because if you don't
we're not turning around that's gonna
mean mom why would you say that to me
why would you say that Mom e we need a
gift for the holidays and we gotta
return some items to afford it remember
the star plushie thing to Jill's the
T-shirt to warm subject and the sponge
to bathroom Delights
is that the name of the store warm
subject or is that what you refer to one
of our family members
I'll pick you up behind the souls try
and get a good gift while you're in
there okay like that box of mac and
I might be a kid but I don't think mac
and cheese is a good gift I don't know
the one with the famous Italian guy on
it if I give it to your pops he'll be a
real happy don't worry you'll be fine
you're a big Brave kid all right see ya
[Music]
mom mom
well I am alone
um wow there's some very useful graffiti
on here
backpack tab I have
something I forget what it is a T-shirt
and a sponge
man we really gotta
we gotta get here no ski masks allowed
it's got an eyeball nice
enter the mall not yet I need to see
what's going on around the mall
God damn this mobile oh
invisible wall sure I wonder what a mall
why is there no one in the mall
I just realized that there were no cars
in the parking lot not even those for
employees where did my mom just drop me
off of from Mom Mom you got some
explaining to do
Ma
okay jills oh hi oh there's someone here
Hi how are you I'm here to return
something cool clerk man you are cool
showed up just a little bit before
closing time all right actually probably
like do my job
hey welcome to jills and stuff you need
any help I got
it whatever this is I have to return it
you want to return right yeah here I'll
give you a Fiverr for this
all right cool one of these star-shaped
sucky things yeah some kids claim these
things start biting them
what for real though you should probably
hurry up and go home it's getting late
uh-huh oh it's you again uh where's
Saul's I don't know why you'd want to go
there but if you continue down the hall
here you can't miss it
girl who mans to death there is nice and
all but she's a little uh well you'll
see when you get there
okay
sounds good to me
close for the whole oh it's a Rainforest
Cafe never mind it's a tropical Diner ah
tropical Diner a wild place to shop and
eat this place is pretty sick in the
cool way
but the food also made you very sick in
the sick way yeah that sounds about
right oh is there something in there
coin the fans full of pretty stale water
how long has it been since this thing's
been cycled seems all the scattered
coins have been picked clean here no
coins left except for one a pretty
obvious big coin sitting against the
ridge of the spout too bad the water in
the fountain is so wet or you could
reach right in there and grab it
too bad it's so wet yeah too bad it's
too blade here's the vending machine
it's got a bunch of really really old
snack bags in it you don't recognize
half the snacks you see here and the
ones you do recognize have logos you've
never seen do you want to buy a bag no
no I do not
too stanky to go in there you need to
get out of here now
what
what am I hearing this music but there's
also footsteps
what is that
what are you okay whatever bye fine ha
hey there big guy
oh
wow
uh-huh
oh yeah
oh
[Music]
how are you I'm okay I guess
why are you speaking all of a sudden
doesn't smell great back here and the
roof is leaking a little so kind of
rough shift but you decide to ask me how
I'm doing no one's really done that here
thanks for that really I'm feeling a
little bit better now I'm usually pretty
shy around people but this was nice
okay
he just gave this to you for free it
doesn't actually look that appetizing
but then now that you're closer up to it
but free is free
you take the pretzel and wrap it up for
now it'd be wrong to eat it here it
would be wrong
so wrong
are there so few people here oh girl
well
okay hey that guy talks like you do
this nonsense in the comments all the
time barely coherent
hey that'd be a good present for Wade
wow dead ass
um
right okay
sorry we're closed it's locked you're
right it is
bathroom Delights I think this is where
I was supposed to return something hey
what's up you look relatively normal
hey yo welcome to bathroom Delights
what's up I gotta return this oh dear uh
really sorry to sell you tell you this
but I don't think I can accept it I
don't know where you got this from but
it definitely couldn't be from our store
they look kind of like ours but they
were taken off the market years ago for
being illegally potent at sucking up
water sorry I really wish I could help
you more have a good one okay I'm almost
closing up real soon
uh is there cool stuff here cool stuff
sure there's lots of cool stuff I mean a
lot of places close down recently but
well I hang out with some of the other
people working here sometimes they're
pretty cool they're not stuff though
sorry
wow you were extremely unhelpful thanks
but I do appreciate you telling me that
it sucks up water hello
whoa
what's one of those cool pet games like
the one from Jill's the screen is broken
and the sound is crackly but it works
and your mom told you not to root around
the trash what does she know
yeah she is stupid all right so maybe I
could use this whoa
warm subject I think this was the last
one right
what is this oh wait a minute
wait a minute
I'm going
oh my God
oh never mind never mind I'm gonna talk
to you first
yo welcome to warm subject uh I gotta
return this return ah yeah no problem
it's 10 bucks back for it what's this
return hero huh someone got you this
shirt but you didn't want to hold on to
it don't worry I can relate I honestly
kind of surprised someone gave me this
this girl's from a pretty obscure show
and it's not exactly for kids
um what's that room over there what room
there's no room you didn't see a room
don't be a snitch
there is no room
hi
how you doing
I can sense it in you but only a little
bit that instinct a spark that has yet
to grow
you're interested
no no I know
I'm not the same as what I'm doing
the same is what I've given up to reach
to reach this point
come back when your collection is
all right cool thanks thanks pal uh I'm
gonna leave now they're all Funko Pops
you know they might just be Funko pops
but uh We're not gonna pass any judgment
on anybody hello
we're not going to pass any judgment on
anybody
maybe I could use the
spoon I'm barely not
hello sir what are you doing up here
hello there
the acetone child I'm very sorry I was
just implementing my lack of large
capital
oh I'm very rich so rich in fact that I
can afford to stand up here all day and
soak but that is not the issue for you
see I'm terribly out of sorts I sure
need far and white for big coin
I found it right down there only I can't
get it's full of water all right A
Generous okay I get it what are you
gonna give me if I give you big coin
I hate water do it
all right
I've done it and so is my sponge
all right water's still there your
sponge is still there too they just
become one single thing a wet sponge is
really heavy you go and snatch up the
big coin weird the moment you pick it up
you feel a pair of wisened old eyes on
you
okay hello
marvelously done child with the water in
the fountain of the big coin retrieved
Victory is in our grasp look how it
shines even after having been a Brand
into the water of the fun for so long
hasn't even collected any rust now your
reward awaits you if you hand me that
delightfully big piece of History many
things my precocious friend now that
there's the legitimacy of this currency
is only a professional can okay
it's delicious there's no doubting it
now this is the real deal all right a
blank check for me
not that you could I promise that no
number you put on there would be enough
to hurt me I'm richer than most
countries as for me this beautiful piece
of History shall go right into my pocket
I can feel it's an expedient way to bug
me
uh
uh well that was weird oh look at you
look at you this is freaking sweet you
wish dinosaurs were real I don't really
wish that all right how's it going hey
there sport like the motto came up silly
me uh can I have that dinosaur oh that's
sorry amigo but no can do a girl there
is a Cornerstone in my business she's
the heart of this business I can't even
think about what I do yeah but check
this out
did I just jump oh my you really knocked
it out of the Block
it's been a long time since I've seen a
trick that sick as in cool it really
brings me back to my childhood can you
show me how you did it yeah for a price
there's a lot I could give for that
knowledge a new couch for your family a
dining table
dinosaur
the unexpected tomorrow
what is this game I thought it was a
horror game is this still a horror game
am I still horrible
I just got a Dino
perfect
my very own
oh wow this uh
[Music]
guys Polar Express 2 just dropped
oh my God Ah that's a damn shame okay
good oh
Papi's graveyard oh no function
interesting
all right well no going that way yeah is
this still a horror game or what I don't
know what's happening here but I'm
getting a lot of presents I think anyway
four of ten wait at bottom left it says
four of ten what is it
oh that's your mustache I was not sure
hey you got it don't you kid that thing
I can smell it from here I might
establish that I can do that it doesn't
matter if I didn't but that's a real
powerful tool you got in your hands
there kid how about it give me the wet
sponge promise I'll make it worth your
while okay Shucks kid really made my day
giving me that should be able to get all
my work done for the night now here is
for you a key should be able to open the
gates of the arcade with that kids like
arcades right
yep kids definitely like arcades I think
I'm finally prize it gets open you feel
confident about your child's strength
now you can enter the arcade great why
[Music]
oh
no
[Music]
oh
do they keep changing
what
wait a minute
wait a minute this wig Uncle would love
this for his head it's quite greasy
oh
oh God
hahaha
okay I got six of ten gifts thank you
everybody oh there's more in here
good
this is so good
thanks for that by the way
uh why do you have this key I'm a
cleaner kid I clean things lots of dirt
out there what needs cleaning sometimes
you got to get to places you ain't
strictly allowed to make sure those
messes get cleaned now get out of here
and
thanks pal
thanks buddy thanks pal
either I've only got six of ten so
there's got to be something else here
backpack looks pretty wet but no it's
not sagging quite as much about that
sponge gave it away probably for the
best this stuff's really dangerous and
my hands out of my I'm sure it's in the
right hands
sure
okay
wow it's so
all right
um so there's gotta be something else
here oh I guess I could uh I guess I
could do the vending machine I wasn't
sure if I needed to
but now I'm assuming that I do so if I
go to the vending machine and I get
whatever what was in there and then
maybe go in the bathroom
a bag of chalks pops out the vending
machine is clearly on the fritz chalks
you're not familiar with the brand but
it advertises itself as a challenge
snack I don't want to know what that is
all right weird bathroom sounds that
guy's still there maybe I'll go back to
that Funko Pop man see what's going on
there
oh
dude that's just blinking me
interesting oh you know it's not like
there's too many things that are scary
happening but it's I'm not comfortable
I'm uncomfy
fan the flames
scrounged
inside everything you could
I haven't met a lot of other people with
this kind of fire I admire that I
appreciate it here then one more for
your collection
I'm grateful grateful to have come here
grateful to have met you
now I know this was all worth it
so
try not to end up like me if you can
help it
it's nice to have a hobby but that's
always true for obsessions
I got a Funko Pop I think I also have a
blank check that would probably be a
good gift you know I bet there's a ton
of stuff to look at here but since he
gave me something for collecting a lot
of some things I'm gonna guess that I
can move on to Saul's to get the rest of
the some things that I might need
because I see some glowies in Sauls
you'd take a seat but you're pretty sure
you'd fall asleep in one of these things
plus they smell like some really bad
cheese thanks nothing in this one hi
whoa is that Brendan Frazier oh wow it's
fair to say his performance in that film
was an absolute breakout your mom loves
this movie and this man can make her
real happy you'd also you'd love to ask
the cashier about the price but she
seems to be asleep huh okay no stop a
bunch of branded macaroni and cheese
boxes spread Loosely on the table Tony's
macaroni
I'm a middlingly successful attempt to
use James gandolfini's likeness to push
back to Macaroni it'd make a middlingly
successful gift but the clerk is
currently too asleep to sell it to you
entered
sting uh
kind of empty in here
kinda
sparse if you ask me
uh-huh huh oh yeah hey can I help you
are you uh trying to buy something
closing up soon if you want any of this
stuff go ahead and like look at it and
stuff
oh you want the Brendan cutouts so like
that's not supposed to be for sale but
if you have a lot of money or something
maybe I could sell it to you it'd have
to be
it'd have to be a really goofy amount
okay goofy
uh uh okay fine yeah sure I'll take that
check and you can yeah yeah it's yours
uh cool oh yeah Tony's macaroni Tony's
macaroni macaronis yeah 15 bucks sure
huh you're like a dog
no
please
huh oh sure fine
oh
okay thanks done shopping if you're all
done your business is done I'm gonna
close up and like the whole Mall will
close up too probably I think I'm done
really last conversation the mole closed
when you agree
I I got 10 of 10 I I don't know what
else to do I got 10 to 10 at 10.
[Applause]
oh wait
what
what do you mean
what do you mean I'm still here what are
you what are you doing what are you
doing
I'm still here
oh no
oh
guys I'm still here oh
hoagie
why do I have to go off the back way
I don't like going out the back way I
think the back way is not the way for me
[Music]
hey what are you doing here what do you
mean
oh hi
hello
oh it's just you sorry I think I was
walking to my car so I could like go
home Hey kid it's like really late is
someone supposed to be picking you up
the exits down this way or um in front
of you sorry I'm a little bleary-eyed I
might take a breather for a sec before I
go home myself
uh oh
um
oh
[Music]
I made it
was that it
did I do it was that it
[Music]
what just happened I don't know what
happened I don't know what a great
Christmas though really good stuff I
think
[Music]
I hope you enjoyed your stay at home our
security cameras have captured you every
move
you know what you did
come back soon and thank you for
choosing our move
[Music]